and we are right now joined by magnus
collins and maybe this is the one
my name is carlson congratulations on
being in the semifinals
thank you how do you feel about today
you you
said yesterday felt a little bit low on
energy one of one great win today and
that was enough how do you feel about
today
i felt a lot better today um
i tried to to play a lot more
aggressively uh take some more more
risks
maybe the first game was a little bit
excessive because i played a line that i
i knew wasn't supposed to be great but i
was just curious to
to find out uh but yeah fortunately i
held that one and
i think the the second game
um he didn't find the right plan early
on and then i was just
positionally winning um and after that
i switched in the third game to to
more solid style again uh and i was okay
i have to say i was slightly worried in
the last
game i i think i was um
i was bungling this ending a little bit
um but i i felt like in general i
i was okay and and then when he made
this move a5
um gave me some time to create the past
one and consolidate
after that it was really really uh easy
but
for for a minute there i was a little
bit a little bit worried but
um probably all right i lost
my sound so i'm not quite sure why
you're saying magnus but
i want to ask you one question because
uh in the second game
you said something about timor not you
know playing his best there but
david actually called this um i have to
read it master class
in strategic dominance by you so how
happy are you about your
play in that game uh i wouldn't
i wouldn't say so uh i i mean after i
got the ponum
on uh on v6 that very very strong pass
spawn i think
um i think i mean i didn't do anything
particularly wrong in that game but i i
don't think
the concepts were very difficult but
obviously it's
very very pleasant to to win uh
games like that where you don't have to
uh where you sort of just follow follow
the plan and win that way
yeah and magnus um it looks like you're
going to play levon aronian and
he in his interview with us he did feel
the ghosts of the last tour event when
you defeated him quite convincingly how
are you going to approach that one
tomorrow um no i
i don't know i think i i have good
chances
in in general but it will probably be
another another difficult match
uh after after all anybody that beats
the big soul is no slouch and
and lavon has shown in plenty of these
these
uh tournaments before that he can he can
do well so
i'm looking forward to it and
obviously mine is we're all wondering um
are you feeling better than ever in the
tour
in this fifth tournament i wouldn't
necessarily say so
uh but what i am happy about
is tested yesterday and that i managed
to come back
a lot better today and i have to say
that in general rajov
is uh is a very very tough opponent in
this
this format since he since he rarely
loses in one one five moment and you
could
you could be out unfortunately i wasn't
wasn't punished yesterday but
um it was quite apparent to me uh from
from my match with him yesterday and
today why
why he's done well in this format
recently
and how have you been feeling magnus
playing at home again after experiencing
the melt water offices
for the first three days what's the
difference what's the comparison
um uh
obviously it's more pleasant to play at
home
since you don't have to you don't have
to to move around pretty
familiar surroundings and so on
um but maybe it's tougher to get into
into into fifth gear um but
anyway both both work fine for me
all right magnus we wish you the best of
luck in semi-finals
thank you thanks for joining us